welcome to this video on playing the
psycho cowboy again Simon Williamson
let's see it's prolly has some something
weird and storm I knew it
definitely not you should have four yeah
okay I will try to play em and play as
solid as possible okay if I go Bishop f5
he very likely will start to push f3 g4
and and things like that but still I
probably have to do it need to get
things developed probably for
immediately or g4 okay okay so let's
check how do i how do i get some play it
should exchange maybe queen a5 and and
night b6 see for this kind of this kind
of ideas are probably not bad let's
let's go for that
I can I don't need to castle here
quickly and that probably also shouldn't
shouldn't I go for that I mean maybe be
393 exchanges Queens I'm glad to do that
interesting maybe a five a four this is
definitely not a bad better structure
for me I have the CFR and I'm very glad
to have an end game because frankly
speaking in the end game I'm quite quite
sure I'm the better player but if it
gets to tactics this guy is absolutely
great so let's see what happens okay
don't I don't mind that trait very much
but it's also not helping me a lot
only slight problem are those pawns on
the dark squares
okay I don't if he trades them maybe f6
Bishop d6 keep it simple approach I
should just take it and this one yes
you know it's probably probably about
equal I don't think there's something
check special going on that's
interesting
I've thought about it but I thought that
after the capture
I mean whoops I can't even take on d4
here by the way rock before work is 6:00
at the end up breaking if hive and rook
f8 that's slightly better endgame for me
really
octi 46 checking in 6 Luke checks
kingi 5 c3 c3 rook F a truck d3
I don't see why format them rock t46
King e6 k e4 e5 c5 King e5c three he's
threatening a foreign fortunately okay
it's not a big deal this is also came
it's really nothing nothing terrible
happening here I always have this count
to play against against f3 and these
ideas with before before twice evening
hmm interesting
check
okay time warning check where drew b7 is
this something like a maid or anything
don't really don't look a sudden I have
King d8 okay Wow 30 seconds left
all kinds of drawers here but
thirty seconds okay seventeen d8 is
definitely okay for Jack I have the
counter idea this is I don't know just
try to get get on the second rank as
well that always must be at least a draw
for black I can always escape with the
King to a four if I want well once you
played h7 Wow ma this is a dirty trick
that's the only way you can win right I
can only laugh about that check check
check
okay black resigns yeah brief move the
pre move trick yeah okay the only way
for him of course to win this game
otherwise after this oops
after this I'm just I'm just at least
equal I mean
rookie seven a form so yeah that's it
wrong really it's nothing nothing
happening nothing happening really in
the the start of the endgame there was
some interesting moments especially here
this is very normal at that sorry here
it's it's very interesting to check this
move check it was very close to being
being excellent for for black but I
couldn't really couldn't really make it
work
I mean obviously I have the far better
King no this is where blacks potential
is
but I don't I really don't have a way to
to enter the position that's a problem
computer s on equal but okay what I did
is no it's certainly okay I mean black
is just okay in this position yeah yeah
I'm better even but this is a good way
to play g5 Jack and so here we are
probably talking about about a drone
simply because of my King is in the open
so he can always get in some some sort
of perpetual check okay there are many
ways to do it but I don't think I can I
can really win here here Luke age three
is clearly better for black but okay I
only had twenty nine seconds I was
thinking about well rook F to rook g2 to
get the drawing and of course yeah well
this is just a pre move tricky way for
himself in the game okay thanks for
watching